star trek strange new worlds has beamed
on to paramount plus
ships named after famous characters star
charts filled with familiar places how
about references to the gorn these are
all the easter eggs you missed in star
trek strange new worlds episode 1.
the premier episode of strange new
worlds opens with a dramatic scene on an
alien world not unlike our own in the
early 21st century as scientists and
military leaders make a startling
discovery an advanced starship has been
spotted above the planet we later
learned that the ship traveled to this
world under the command of una chin
reilly captain pike's number one but
it's the name of the starship that
offers up our first easter egg
designated the uss archer is a clear
reference to one of starfleet's greatest
captains and the star of the 2001 series
enterprise played by scott bakula archer
was captain of the nx01 before the
founding of the federation and helped
shape the creation of the interplanetary
organization at the helm of enterprise
starting in 2150 jonathan archer made
first contact with any number of alien
worlds during his time in the captain's
chair many of which we saw in the four
seasons series as such it makes sense
that a ship assigned to first contact
missions would bear his name in the 23rd
century it's also not the first uss
archer we've seen as another ship with
the same name was mentioned in the 10th
feature film star trek nemesis released
just a year after enterprise launched on
television
interestingly the 23rd century version
single nay cell setup bears a
resemblance to the uss kelvin the
starship scene at the opening of the
2009 star trek reboot directed by jj
abrams called back into service by
admiral bob christopher bike finds
himself in a starfleet uniform once
again and being ferried to a space dock
where the enterprise is waiting for him
he is taken by a young star fleet
officer aboard a shuttlecraft that bears
a striking resemblance to the shuttles
seen on star trek the original series
reimagined and redesigned for the new
series the name of that shuttle provides
our next easter egg calling station
control the officer announces her
arrival aboard the shuttle stamets it
doesn't take a die-hard trekkie to know
the shuttle as a reference to star trek
discovery star anthony rapp and his
character paul stamets the federation's
leading astromycologist but why would
starfleet canonize him by naming a
shuttle after an active starfleet
scientist well because technically
stamets is no longer active in this era
at the conclusion of season 2 of star
trek discovery the uss discovery must
travel into the far future to save
billions of lives from a galactic threat
due to the nature of the threat the
mission was classified and starfleet
considered the vessel lost with all
hands all officers remaining with
knowledge of these events must be
ordered never to speak of discovery its
war drive or her crew again as far as
anyone on strange new worlds is
concerned the entire crew is dead
including stamets it was seen that not
long after the ship's destruction
starfleet commemorated the officer by
naming one of enterprises shuttles after
him this is an appropriate honor as it
fits the enterprise's theme of naming it
shuttlecraft after famous scientists
with the original series featuring
shuttles named for historic thinkers
like galileo and einstein
during the enterprise's mission to kylie
279 a landing party is assembled
consisting of captain pike acting first
officer la'ann nooni in sync and science
officer spark in addition to feeling
like a classic tos era away mission they
are beamed down by their transporter
chief who pike refers to as chief kyle
just don't lose my socks mr carl he
later plays a crucial role in the
success of the mission using an
ingenious and inventive technique to
beam down a serum into spock's eyes to
allow him to pass through a retinal
scanner on the planet's surface eagle
leone fans will recognize that chief
kyle is not a new character created for
this series but one whose origins date
back to the original star trek series
appearing in nearly a dozen episodes the
chief went unnamed for several stories
until spock addressed him as kyle and
who mourns for adonis he later appears
in a small role in star trek 2 the wrath
of khan and even pops up briefly in the
2009 big budget reboot from jj abrams
the original role was played by english
actor john winston while the rebooted
version was played by chris duhan son of
original scotty actor james duhan here
chief kyle is played by actor andre day
kim
as spark briefs the captain he pulls up
a star chart of the region providing
perhaps the episode's best easter egg
moment worthy of a long pause the star
chart is filled with so many references
to past episodes we could write an
entire article on just the shot alone
clearly visible are cardassia prime and
bajo the two key worlds at the center of
star trek deep space nine the chart is
also littered with other familiar worlds
including vulcan andoria and trill the
claystrong system is not far from trill
which makes sense as it was the home
planet of one of dax's former lovers we
also see mizar the system that was the
home of thal and core karalai which is
where captain picard cured a plague both
of which are featured in the next
generation
from tos and enterprise we see places
such as sigma draconis talos corridin
and sherman's planet in addition azati
prime and denobila from enterprise are
depicted appropriately as not far from
earth one particularly important
location is the star wolf of 359 it's
here where the borg under the command of
locutus decimated the federation fleet
on its way to earth and where benjamin
cisco's life was changed forever
back aboard the enterprise after their
mission away on kylie 279 pike spock and
nuni and singh speak again in a briefing
room there they discuss how to proceed
with a pre-warp culture that is
attempting to use advanced technology
copied from scans of a federation
starship as a weapon
at this moment we learned about nunian
singh's past and the traumatic childhood
incident that shaped her into the woman
she has become you know the gorn
captured my family's colony ship
and deposited us on one of their
planetary nurseries as we saw earlier on
a pad the incident involved the gone a
species we've seen in live-action star
trek only twice before in the classic
tos episode arena starfleet makes first
contact with the gorn who have attacked
the federation colony on cestus 3. the
enterprise as captain james kirk finds
himself in a life or death battle with a
gorn soldier in one of that series most
iconic moments years later on enterprise
we'd see the gone again though this time
it would be in the mirror universe where
a gone slave master named sla is in
charge of prisoners held aboard a
futuristic starship from a parallel
reality the defiant the premiere of
strange new worlds explains that the
gorn have nurseries and keep human
captives as food and breeding sacks
adding a gruesome new background to the
lizard-like alien race as a gone figure
into la aunt's backstory heavily it's
possible we might finally see them again
in later episodes of strange new worlds
the first episode of strange new worlds
is appropriately centered on a first
contact mission to a world we've never
seen before kylie 279 in the best star
trek tradition the story revolves around
the classic dilemma of whether or not to
get involved in the affairs of a more
primitive culture and society that has
not yet achieved interstellar travel
to do so would potentially violate the
prime directive though discussed heavily
in the episode some fans may find it
curious that pike and his crew refer to
the directive however as general order
one that's because in the original star
trek that's what the prime directive is
called up until about midway through the
series when the writers reshape the
lexicon that shift is referenced by the
starfleet admiral that beats with pike
spark and number one at the end of the
episode who knows that the order might
need a new name thanks to pike's
reckless disregard of order one he says
that starfleet is renaming it the prime
directive pike rolls his eyes and
responds
that'll never stick this is both an
in-universe explanation for the back and
forth naming of starfleet's highest
order in the original series and a meta
reference to the inconsistencies
throughout early star trek history
early in the premiere episode of strange
new worlds we're teamed with a
surprising name drop when captain pike
mentions a starfleet officer named
lieutenant kirk it's an eye-popping
moment could the future enterprise
captain appear in the first episode with
pike reassembling his staff and
personally selecting several new
officers for the latest crew rotation it
seems he's asked for kirk specifically
as spock notes while they walk through
the enterprise's corridors near the end
of the episode first officer una chin
reilly tells pike that lieutenant kirk
has finally arrived on the enterprise
and is on his way to the bridge as
requested but when the officer walks
through the doorway we see it as not a
yellow shirt to james t kirk but a blue
shirted science officer with a
surprisingly thick mustache pike greets
the lieutenant shaking his hand and
addressing him as samuel kirk however
this is more than just a clever gag to
bait and switch the audience as samuel
kirk is a character briefly seen in an
episode of star trek in 1967 titled
operation annihilate in the episode
deadly parasites attack an earth colony
on denver causing mass insanity and
taking many lives including that of
captain kirk's brother sam we never see
the brother of james kirk in action but
we do get a look at his body after his
death and he's played by none other than
william shatner who sports a thick
hollywood mustache it's already been
revealed that james kirk himself is set
to appear in season 2 so it will be
interesting to see if his brother sam
figures into any future stories
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]